[Music]
anybody here a fan of piranhas i love
pride those are cool yo piranha tempura
is the greatest ever no really weird
oh i had all of you guys not all of you
i was down i was really down i was like
it's really good but it sounds pretty
good i'm sure amazon cultures eat
piranhas why wouldn't they of course
they do right why would they be super
down it could be like it's so funny
why would i eat a catfish and not a
piranha ah very true you know what i
mean you know i smuggled and sold
piranhas yeah he's a he was a piranha
dealer they're illegal
you're a problem you didn't hear the
story i told this story here i want one
yeah i would put it in my bathtub oh
this was me in heist you got to buy a
bunch of them though i just want one
high school yeah i want to get it really
big i'm going to overfeed it
all like exotic fish
yeah but piranhas were were highly
valuable because well not bad they're
actually cheap but they're they're
highly sought after because in high
school everyone wants a [ __ ] piranha
they're like you got a piranha and then
like you could buy a bag of them for
like
i don't know like less than a buck
because the best way to do it was you
get them this small and then you raise
them and then you get it to full size
and then like you could sell them like i
don't know like 10 bucks or whatever and
then when people come over they'll be
like yeah i want those [ __ ] piranhas
but like watch this and you just throw
goldfish they [ __ ] destroy that
[ __ ] you throw some like you
know like some rat or some [ __ ] they
[ __ ] them up you know and you're like
that's a piranha and then sold if that's
the best easy you're like just bring
your baby brother over
and look like how many can i get and i'm
like well you know and then you just
sell them out and then you just keep
repeating that process dude wow yeah
i'm gonna start selling you are such a
business
story train your piranha were you able
to train your piranha to do tricks nah
because i i mean they would go it was a
piranha farm you know like just shorter
yeah just had a bunch of fish tanks in
different stages and you just keep
raising where would you source that you
would get him from at the time he went
to the amazon by himself when he was in
high school amazon.com there was a lot
of piranha traffic original amazon.com
used to only sell piranhas
that was their first item that they sold
which they had over the market it was
like it was books and piranhas silk road
for piranhas dude
our friends our friend's dad
his good friend owned a pet store
and it was literally like one of those
like movies where in the back they had
the special [ __ ]
so like what else do we have animals
children no like yeah illegal illegal
fish adrenochrome homo sapiens
it was like goldfish [ __ ] frogs
whatever right when you go to the back
they had the [ __ ] arowanas the the
special kinds that cost like thousand
dollars per per each one the one that
you see at the chinese uh restaurants
and [ __ ] are those illegal to sell those
are legal in america some of them are
yeah the ones you see is silver arowana
the asian arowanas are illegal here
there are uh and there's predator fish
called like snakeheads they're they're
illegal here is it because they're
invasive species well yeah if they if
they run out i mean if they get out if
they run i mean um they'll get yeah
they'll [ __ ] some [ __ ] they'll mutate
yeah but the way they literally they'll
start running
they should get thighs
[ __ ] vicious though it's cool like
you throw crickets in there and they go
it's [ __ ] cool man damn so there was
a mass piranha attack that resulted in a
teenager having uh their toe bitten off
and 30 others being injured oh whoa [ __ ]
no was this in the wild
or was it that somebody's illegal they
jumped into a school of piranha fish and
we didn't expect anything to happen i
mean low-key yes
yeah yeah that's kind of how it works i
thought a prankster brought like a trash
can full of product dumping in the pool
name's joe got you
senior prank
oh dude piranhas are [ __ ] dude i used
to always do this to like make people go
whoa and then so like after they're well
fed right they don't care you could
stick your hand in there clean stuff and
whatever and they just run away from you
because they're so scared
that definitely yeah but they were
leaving they were living that human
lifestyle they're waiting for you to
feed them oh yeah it became they became
like the wally
like they became all obese in their
electrical chairs
lifeguards at santa fe
uh piranha river rushed to the aid of
family it's called piranha river called
piranha these guys are dumb here's the
dog that's what you get
yeah they had the rush of the aid of
families and swimmers when a storm of
piranha started attacking in shallow
water including the 30 injured victims
was a teenage girl who has since been
taken to the hospital for emergency skin
grafting treatment on her toes
it's been reported that other victims
went to a nearby hospital to have
injuries to their fingers and hands and
all that stuff treated as well they hit
the limbs first
the phalanges
i should call my dad ask him if he's
ever worked on a piranha plant
mario
[Laughter]
my dad's a hand surgeon i know he's
operated on people that have been bit by
monkeys no way yeah
because they have pet monkeys and he's
like you're an idiot you have a pep
your [ __ ] finger and they bite your
finger and they're like you know oh
there's a diagnosis you're an idiot he's
like oh so what happened
well dr monkey bit my hand he's like
well you're a [ __ ] idiot
that's what he said in my head that's
probably not what he said
that's what you say to me for sure
that's [ __ ] tight but at a certain
point time you have to say this stuff or
you're or you're not responsible i mean
he is a doctor so he has to eat and you
know what the [ __ ] are you doing his
medical advice and his medical advice is
that he's that problem that person is
probably a [ __ ] idiot i mean [ __ ]
piranha piranha river was really the
name yeah so
sergio barrardi a union representative
for lifeguards in the river confirmed
that the attack they have life claims it
was certainly unexpected blaming it on
high temperatures in shallow waters
because people usually do go into the
river but it's called piranha river it
is i think it's it's honestly they don't
have tests where they know where the
piranhas are coming around
in brazil i'm not going to swim at shark
beach
walk down sex offender boulevard
where's the federal bar it's valley
valley view
orange shore oh
[ __ ] kidding it's nice i live next to
that
i'm a sex offender that's why you have
such a low mortgage we got death valley
out here in california
have you ever googled the sex offenders
that live around you i have yeah i've
done that there's a website there's a
website yeah because it's public
information check my neighborhood bro
what's the website anybody near you ah
there's a website what's it called it's
a sex offender
uh
dude can you believe this to find the
sex offenders i first have to find the
tractor
you're stumped stumped you're stumped
they're trying to capture the sex
offenders halfway in my ass come on man
i'm sorry okay we're gonna search a
five-mile radius we're gonna include
transient offenders i don't know what
the [ __ ] that means
homeless offenders got it okay
oh [ __ ] bro
no way this is like the times square of
steps
what's the blue ones me yo
sh magmas
holy [ __ ] exclusively
oh
yo bro there's one guy who lives
literally one block away from you they
probably my neighbor so you know on on
on hill and route 66 dude you better
watch oh it's an asian dude
yo bro it hasn't got his name pictures
y'all
sex offenders
[Music]
this uh this lifeguard dude at the
[ __ ] piranha river says we cannot
stress enough the importance of heeding
the warnings of the lifeguards
especially families with children now we
have seen the damages these piranhas can
do when the lifeguards see one or two of
the people being bitten they
automatically order people out of the
water but often this action is not
enough or efficient because of the
amount of people in the area and on
sunday afternoon the lifeguards on duty
were rushed off their feet trying to
deal with all the people who had
suffered bite injuries at the same time
these fish tend to move in shoals so we
get a lot of simultaneous attacks we
didn't expect what happened to occur
before summer even starts here if people
take a quick dip in the water they
should be okay but the best thing is to
take advantage of the showers that are
installed on the beach so yes
[ __ ] go into this [ __ ]
piranha space all the time called
piranha river but it's usually expected
that in the summer warmer waters when
the water gets shallow that's when it
happens but but maybe climate change you
know yeah global warming
maybe i don't know guys we gotta cool
this [ __ ] down open up that freezer here
y'all simultaneously open up our
freezers and [ __ ] refrigerators yeah
you could dump ice into the oceans yeah
yeah we had done some ice in the oceans
yeah i thought about that how about 24
7. ice cream jazz block called
antarctica that we could probably chip
away at
just melt just keep but then then
miami's gonna sink miami's already
sinking
long island is gone
you know what actually did [ __ ] me up
didn't they say uh both venice
uh not venezuela venice like italy and
also the taj mahal are sinking and
eroding in such ways well i think that's
because the taj mahal is on like on
swamp land is that what it is yeah
apparently like less than a hundred
years
i think if i remember
venice is less than 100 years and taj
mahal is like less than like 20. i
better go yeah
sometimes what is that church there
they'll be covered in water there's
water damage
because i mean i was pretty close i went
to this place in um it's called the
venetian in in las vegas yesterday i was
drowning too were you drowning in
margaritas
because they got those big
[ __ ] things bro [ __ ] tattoos then
you hit a buffet first trap dude i was
like italy italy this is good
so
[Music]
[Music]